some people think that finding a love on
the master or bachelorette is an
impossible mission but that's not the
case for former bachelorette Jojo
Fletcher and his et online lauren zima
found out she and Beyonce Jordan Rogers
are rootin for Becca to find her happily
ever after
how much do you keep up with the show
these days are you enjoyed watching we
are you know this is actually the first
time that we've been watching the show
since our season is your advice to pack
on handling the drama just take it like
I said one day at a time try not to
listen to the negative outside voices
focus on your relationship and it has
been two years since Jordan popped the
question is Jojo but these days the duo
is more focused on home remodeling than
walking down the aisle
she's even chronicled many of her
projects on Instagram whose hand here
you were Jordan because I feel like we
saw you more doing probably me he's
really good though at like just taking a
sledgehammer and just going to town now
we're teaming up with Jojo and Marcus by
Goldman Sachs to help you get a better
backyard this summer what made you want
to team up with Marcus by Goldman Sachs
it was such a natural fit for me I think
the biggest question or the most common
question I get is where do I start how
do I get my budget in order so when
Marcus by Goldman Sachs came to me and
showed me their home improvement loan it
was amazing they offer this fixed-rate
No Fee home and Sue belongs up to
$40,000 which is a lot and the greatest
thing is for homeowners they can use
these funds however they would like so
that's a benefit ever many homeowners
getting that backyard space in order is
key what do you like to do to spice up a
summer outdoor party well I love summer
times if I love being outdoors
one of the biggest things that I think
I'm seeing lately and it's very
functional is doing outdoor kitchens you
kind of want to be an area where you're
gathering with people so to have a full
prep kitchen outdoors I think it's
amazing and I am woman in my home
actually now
[Music]
you
[Music]